PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So far, we've talked
all things global load balancing
on Google Cloud Platform.
STEPHANIE WONG:
But how does this
work with Google Kubernetes
clusters running as backends?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Since last time, Beyond
Treats' online business
has still been booming.
And, while they upgraded to
using Google's global load
balancer, they also
decided to move
to a microservices environment
for their web backend.
STEPHANIE WONG:
But load balancers
were initially built to
support resource allocation
for virtual
machines, which helps
workloads be highly available.
When containers and
container orchestrators
started to take off, users
adapted these VM-unfocused load
balancers for their use,
even though the performance
was suboptimal.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Traditionally, HTTPS load
balancers, targeting
Kubernetes clusters,
would actually be
targeting its nodes
because they didn't have a
way to recognize each pod.
In the absence of a way
to define a group of pods
as backends, the load
balancer used instance groups
to group VMs as a backend.
Ingress support in GKE,
using those instance groups,
used the HTTPS load balancer
to perform load balancing
to nodes in the cluster.
STEPHANIE WONG: IP
table rules programmed
on the nodes raw
request to the pod
serving as backends for the
load balanced application.
Load balancing to the
nodes was the only option
since the load balancer didn't
recognize pods or containers
as backends, resulting
in imbalanced load
and a suboptimal data path with
additional unnecessary hops
between nodes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
But then Google
came out with Network
Endpoint Groups,
or NEGs, abstraction layer that
enables container native load
balancing.
This means the load balancer
has visibility into a Kubernetes
cluster pods because
NEGs are integrated
with the Kubernetes ingress
controller running on GCP.
In the case for
Beyond Treat, they
have a multi-tiered
e-commerce deployment
and want to expose one service
to the internet using GKE.
With NEGs, they can
now provision and HTTPS
load balancer, allowing
them to configure
pad-based or host-based
routing to their backend pods.
STEPHANIE WONG: All they
have to do to get started
is to create a
VPC-native GKE cluster.
By default, Kubernetes
uses static routes
for pod networking, which
requires a Kubernetes control
plane to maintain these
routes to each node.
But this comes at
a scaling cost.
In GKE, you have the
option to create clusters
in VPC-native mode,
which provides container
native load balancing
that uses a NEG model.
VPC-native mode means
you have connectivity
between all pods in your VPC
without the overhead of route
scaling.
And traffic is
evenly distributed
among the available healthy
backends in an input group.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now that
Beyond Treat has implemented
a VPC-native cluster
with NEGs, they've
experienced even
better load balancing.
With container-native
load balancing,
traffic is distributed evenly
among the available healthy
backends in an endpoint group,
following their defined load
balancing algorithm.
STEPHANIE WONG: They also
now have native support
for health checking including
TCP, HTTPS, HTTP/2 checks.
NEGs can check the pods
directly rather than
the nodes forwarding health
checks to a random pod.
As a result, health checks
more accurately mirror
the health of the backends.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Beyond
Treat also benefits
from graceful termination,
meaning, when a pod is removed,
the load balancer automatically
drains the connection
to the endpoint,
serving traffic based
on the connection draining
period configured for it.
STEPHANIE WONG: And, best
yet, their pet lovers
will experience their traffic
hitting an optimal data path.
With the ability to load
balance directly to containers,
the traffic hot from the
load balancer to the node
disappears since
load balancing is
performed in a single
step rather than two.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And Beyond Treat now
has increased
visibility and security.
Container-native
load balancing helps
them troubleshoot their
services at the pod level.
It can preserve the source IP
to make it easier to trace back
to the source of the traffic.
Since the container sees the
packet arrive from the load
balancer rather than through a
source NEG from another node,
they can now create firewall
rules using node level network
policies.
STEPHANIE WONG: It looks
like Beyond Treat has
gone from the
popular, local bakery
to an international,
online bakery phenomenon.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And its GCP backend
has grown along with it.
We learned about the load
balancing options on GCP
and proved that
global load balancing
is more performant and reliable
than regional HTTPS load
balancing.
STEPHANIE WONG: And,
finally, we showed you
that, even with GKE clusters,
container-native load balancing
means they can target
back in pods directly
for optimal traffic
distribution and improvements
in scalability.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, we've been talking
about trees for weeks,
and Bell still hasn't
gotten to try any.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
we can get her to try some.
That's all for today on
Get Cooking in Cloud.
Let us know how you're liking
this series in the comments
section, and hit those
like and subscribe buttons
for more cool Google
Cloud content.